an impressive way to start this ball
game well that's a good crisp play
i mean three guys touch him but how
quickly does the ball move in ivy dion
johnson out of tennessee
21st pick last year has five
ivy another three ball this one is pure
get some defensive drills in the
all-around game but nothing mark takes
the place of putting time in spending
time with the coaches
in practice your man just hit a three
right there
cars are trying to post up got
bayheim on his back but they turn it
over two-on-one ivy on the alley-oop
showtime
in vegas nice job by key you've talked
about the keys made a number of good
plays that call tonight doris i saw that
eye roll
vl ivy mom
off the kickout
[Applause]
that's what he does
an imperious dynamic
as you look at his
you know
dynamic style i watched ross playing the
west coast conference tournament
a couple of seasons ago and
he was really good and that's really
good ivy
ball kind of slipped out of his hands it
looked like doris 100
ivy turns a corner boy that's a big time
finish
[Music]
exhibiting his best strength offensively
[Applause]